this sounds silly but like you can plug  into the universe's money and then you  can have as much money as you want so  for example let's say I was working with  you know hair stylists typically not  what most people would consider a very  affluent you know demographic now  there's plenty of them and it's  definitely a niche  um but they're not considered I would  say you know super wealthy  but if I know how to Market and sell and  and deliver high value services and I  show them how to do that and they can  immediately generate let's say five  thousand ten thousand dollars using a  system that I've you know put together  for them so they can run their business  model I don't need them to have money I  need my system to work and then have the  system make them enough money to pay me  and that's the key Point like with with  any of these things it's like I've never  operated on how much money someone has I  operate on how much money I can make  them